I spoke to you a little bit about Good
Omens today and I have to ask you
something that I've been dying to talk
about which is I believe you're part of
a Tom Cruise movie and what the hell is
that like to be in a Top Gun movie with
Tom Cruise I think it's probably weirder
for him to be on the same sets that he
was on some 30 odd years ago and a lot
of the same costumes it's a very strange
experience but it was it's been it's
been a wonderful experience as well you
know it's basically getting the whole
team back together and fortunately Tony
Scott unavailable but they've achieved a
very similar 5:24 and I think it's gonna
be for the people that love the first
movie I think it's going to be very
interesting to watch
it very much takes the story into a
different direction but I think for the
new the new the new fans it's going to
be something very cool too I've seen
some of the footage
honestly well one of the things Joseph
is a very talented director and visually
he has a very unique style I'm curious
what was it like collaborating with him
and what can you tease about your roles
much about the role but if they're using
some technology on this that is never
never before seen shooting the movie in
the thick 6k so it's incredibly high def
and the aerial footage is is because
it's mostly practical there's not a lot
of
so this those guys are really up in
planes getting thrown around
and multiple G's I've heard I've heard
Tom takes people up and makes basically
everyone throw up so did you get to go
out